hello everyone and welcome to another
very
very awesome game uh from the netflix
news series the queen's gambit and uh
we've already shown one game elizabeth's
game versus world champion vasily borgo
and while showing you that game i
immediately told you which
game it was actually based upon from uh
from real life but here we're not going
to do that
uh we're gonna just show you the game
and then i'm gonna let you guess who is
the player
uh you know uh driving the white pieces
as
i thought it'd be an interesting thing
to to try uh and
in this game uh even if you haven't
watched the show like if you want to
watch the show first and then come back
and check out this video you're
welcome to do so uh but i'm not gonna be
spoiling anything from the show we're
just gonna talk about this game
and um if not like incredibly careful
and you know watching it like this
you're not gonna
pick up on a lot of it from from the
actual show so here uh
she faces a dudley dursley from harry
potter but also
uh harry beltik in this uh in this uh
series
uh who is one of her uh adversaries uh
throughout the show
and it's a very very uh incredible
attacking game so uh let's just dive
straight into it and
see what you guys make of it so
elizabeth opens with
e4 as she always does in the final game
against
um vasily borgo we said that uh like
bobby fischer she opened with
d4 but okay we have c6 uh
belting goes for the karo khan defense
we have knight to f3 and now
d5 striking in the center attacking the
e4 pawn
and elizabeth goes knight to c3 defends
the pawn and
inviting uh black to try and overextend
with the d4 however this isn't a a very
good idea
so bishop to g4 instead pinning that
knight and
now immediately h3 asking do you want to
go back with the bishop do you want to
go bishop to h5 or do you want to
capture
uh and here beltic captures it is the
way to play this variation and
e6 now so you've eliminated your light
square bishop
put all your pawns on light squares and
now you are left with a dark square
bishop
uh that's free to roam uh the squares
in between the the pawns that are on
light squares uh we have g3 but uh uh
prepares the fiance to the light square
bishop and castle king side and here we
have g6 knight to f6
is what would have been played today if
this was a modern game
but as this is based on a fairly fairly
old game
we have g6 here black prepares the
fiance to the dark square bishop
uh we bishop the g2 by beth preparing
the castle and bishop to g7
and in the game uh sorry in the in the
actual show
uh beltick uh just blitzes out all of
the moves he's uh very very
very strong on theory here and he knows
his karo khan
uh so here we have castles by beth and
uh
here it was in this position that harry
beltic started yawning he was like
oh and this really annoyed elizabeth
as uh well uh you know
she she gets easily annoyed in the
series but you'll you'll see what i mean
if you watch the actual series
uh we have knights to d7 belting just
continues playing while yawning
and it is as of move eight that this
position has never been reached again so
now uh
we are following that one game that this
uh game in the show is based upon
and the queen back to e2 making room for
uh for the pawns now
you can play d4 if f4 and so on uh so
d4 by black not allowing white to
advance the d
pawn and elizabeth has to go back with
the knight so knight to b1 you could
also go to d1 but
elizabeth wants to go to d1 play d3 and
then shift the knight into the game this
way
we have e5 black strength in the the
center and
now d3 and the bishop also helps out
with the defense of the f4 square so you
are now
more than ready to play f4 we have
knight to e7
now baltic is ready to castle and f4
while the black king is still in the
center of the board so here are queen to
c7
uh adding more defense to the center the
rooks are now
well almost connected once the king
decides where he's going to castle
either king side or queen side
we have a4 kind of discouraging black
from castle in queenside as
white will be it will be very quick to
start pushing those pawns
so here uh beltig decides the castle
king side we have castles and beth
now uh i'm very happy to to start an
attack against the black king
goes f6 and for the moment uh sorry f5
the first moment the f6 square is
defended twice so you don't have to
worry about any pushes of f6 but
uh yeah for that reason this knight is
now stuck here guarding that
so to fix this baltic plays f6 uh
prevents y from playing f6 later on and
now
uh you can you can freely move the
knight so here we have knight to d2
you have to continue developing and now
bishop to h6 baltic says okay once you
move the knight i want to trade off my
dark square bishops
uh i want to apply king to h8 and then
bring the rook over here as the g file
will probably open up so i might as well
put my rooks on the g file
so here king h2 by beth as she's
expecting this we have
kinked the h8 by baltic and now beth
trades once on g6 we have captures
captures and only now
knight to f3 so the knight will be able
to come to h4
put some pressure on g6 uh but in doing
so uh beth also allows the exchange of
the dark square
bishops and this is what belty goes for
uh bishop captures on c1 we have rook
a captures on c1 and now knight to c5 as
the knight can finally move
and now while you could go for h4h5 try
to bust open the position this way here
beth attacks the center with c3
as was played in the actual game which
we still don't know
uh which game it is so here knight the
b3 first now there's a double attack on
the pawn here captures and captures is
the idea
so first knight to b3 beltick attacks uh
beth's
rook here on c1 so she reacts of course
to this rook c to d1
and now rook 8 d8 defending the pawn one
more time
and saying uh my position is uh is very
nice here so here
knight to h for by beth again saying
okay this knight
can't really move otherwise knight
captures on g6 wins the game on the spot
so here uh beltik decides to improve the
position of his queen because this
knight is
pretty nicely placed the the rooks are
very nice uh
but the queen isn't doing all that much
so queen to c8
preparing to sort of centralize the
queen as much as possible with queen to
e6 the queen will uh
be doing a lot there as well as guarding
the knight on b3
uh so here we have bishop to f3 now
preparing to
get the bishop into the game with bishop
to g4 however queen to e6 by baltic
and now bishop to g4 uh nonetheless we
have queen to f7
uh and now comes knight to f3 and here
you can see it's very dangerous the
queen is on the same file as the rook
here knight captures on e5 would be very
unfortunate for black
so beltic has to react to this he moves
the queen now of course knight captures
on e5 does nothing
and now beth continues the attack with
h4
uh we have kink the g7 now the king will
also help out with the defense of the
pawns and
black might even be able to use the h
file for attack
uh we have rook to f2 white now is ready
to double up rooks here on the f
file and rook to d6 and rook to d6 is a
bit of an unfortunate move
uh because after beth's next move which
is rook d to f1
uh the rook is kind of misplaced here
you have to bring it back
uh because knight captures here would be
deadly if the pawn captures just real
captures you have to give up the queen
or you just
lose the whole rook it's uh completely
lost
so here you have to go back this is what
baltic does
and now we have queen to c2 another way
you could try uh is
h5 which also uh must open the position
however here we have queen to c2
and now again could be could be very
dangerous the queen is now
here stuck guarding the knight as the
white queen is attacking it
and here black just goes b6 uh
improving the position preparing to play
c5
and if you want to try knight captures
an e5 with the idea that
maybe everything gets exchanged on f8
and then you pick up the knight it
doesn't work because the king can also
capture the rook we can even show
it if some of you uh don't believe me
now the queen doesn't have the capture
rather the king captures and the knight
is defended black is just up a piece so
for the moment it doesn't work however
we have h5 now and
this is uh this is a a beautiful moment
in the actual show because this
game is based on a on a game of one of
my favorite
chess players ever and there is a
stronger move in the position than h5
h5 is a straight out attacking move
however there is this
c4 idea uh that's uh considered a lot
stronger
uh and we even have a moment in the show
uh some episode uh a few episodes
after this actual game is played uh
elizabeth meets another chess player who
tells her that c4 was actually better in
this position
and then she she gets very angry as she
often gets angry and then she
uh you know sets up the position on the
board and checks out if c4 was actually
stronger and here
uh here's the uh the cl the little clip
from the show where she looks at this
position plays c4 and she realizes
uh yeah c4 here would would have
actually been better but
it's uh never happened in the in the
show and it never happened in the actual
game so we're not going to analyze c4
but
just uh just to give you an idea of how
uh
they were uh you know very detail
detail-oriented uh
in the show but which is not surprising
as they had uh gary kasparov and bruce
pandelfini
uh helping out with uh with everything
uh tho those are the two i know of there
there might be others
so here h5 like in the actual game uh
and
here uh we have c5 by baltic uh so
continuing his play on the
queen side we have h captures and g6 and
now
d captures on c3 uh we have b
captures on c3 and now c4 and now
also defending the knight and asking
whites to mess up his pawns
to mess up her pawn structure so here d4
instead
grabbing the strong center we have
captures and captures and here
uh uh uh uh somewhere around the
disposition
uh i think it was after knight captures
on d4 uh baltic attacked the queen he
put pressure on the night
uh uh beth ran off to the bathroom she
said i'll be right back and then she
you know not gonna spoil anything for
you but uh
there was some something happening in
the bathroom you have to watch the
series to know what happened in the
bathroom and then she came back
and then she just continued the game but
when she came back
she seemed like a million times more
focused than
than she was uh prior to her leaving
for the bathroom uh but okay here beth
continues with knight characters on d4
we have rook captures on d4 and now the
very calm e5 and e5 is a monster move uh
uh offering a bishop sacrifice here
however if the
if the bishop is accepted he captures on
f6 just completely destroys black uh for
example
you you can't really go anywhere uh i
mean
you're going to either lose the knight
then you're going to lose everything and
if you try something like rook captures
on f6 there's a rook captures on f6 and
that's it
you're already up material black doesn't
really have anything and if you try some
sort of a
perpetual with uh king to h8 to check
you're gonna get queen g2 queen eight
check and now king h3 comes with an
attack on the rook so once
you react to this let's say queen e4 now
it's rook f7 check and you just pick up
more material so it's a very simple
position to win
king h6 let's say queen b2 going after
the king
and uh black doesn't have any way of
checking the white king or even trying
to
uh to achieve some perpetual here so you
might as well offer a queen trade but
after captures captures and captures
the nightfalls white is up a whole rook
of course completely winning
so after this e5 idea uh baltic says all
right i'm gonna play f5
as i mean i i have i have no other
options and
elizabeth just plays bishop captures on
f5 and now again a very interesting
moment
there is a way for beltick to get out of
this mess but he has to play knight
captures on f5 and it's very
counter-intuitive
but we will show it just because it's
incredibly interesting
uh point is you have to give up the
knight like this rook captures
on f5 and now queen to h8 to check not
give up the knight i meant trade
king to g2 and now queen to h6 you give
up the rook this is the point but it's
incredibly
difficult to find because the thread is
rook to d2 check
which would uh sort of that which would
win the white queen that's the idea
so here uh white wouldn't really have
the option of capturing the rook you'd
have to play something like rook f7
check
captures captures a width check and
after king to g8 then
queen to f5 to uh you have to avoid
check but now
uh black can check the white king with
the rook both on d3 and on d2 and that's
enough for a draw rook d2
checking f3 are going to go rook d3
checking g2
and so on if you go king e to then queen
the e3 just wins for black so here
uh white has to be satisfied with a
perpetual
so knight captures on f5 was the way to
go here for beltick and he could have
drawn the game however
he played queen to d5 here he wanted to
win the game
and uh well now you can see that rook to
h8 could be very dangerous the queen
also guards h1 so let's say rookie chad
king g1
uh rook the h1 checkmate such ideas
are in the air uh however here beth
uh has a a beautiful move uh you know in
the style of the person that
you know this game is uh who actually
played the game so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the absolute best move for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
uh so for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations
on your uh no reverse gear philosophy
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's
bishop to e6 bishop to h3 is also a
strong move but
it's not in the in the spirit of this
game so bishop to e6
attacking the queen bishop to e6 always
a famous move if you remember bobby
fischer's game of the century
uh but now attacking the queen and also
with an attack on the rook on f8 and
here beltik started uh
you know saying some pretty bad words uh
and uh
he said this quote about the board no no
like uh i can get out of this and that
was like
i i don't think so and uh she
she was right kind of you could get out
of this but you have to be
very very precise so here rook the h8
was played
capturing here just loses the rook so
that's not an option so rook to h8
check uh and now comes uh or you could
play
rook captures on f2 also we have to
consider this because it attacks the
white queen however
after queen captures and queen captures
here uh queen to f8 is just game over
king captures on g6 and rook f6
check picks up the the black queen and
it's all over
so getting back to the actual game after
bishop to e6 we have rooked the
h8 wit check and now now it's
uh well if you move king g1 queen to h1
is checkmate as the rook and queen
nicely
uh cover this but uh elizabeth doesn't
have to move the king and here
uh it's weird in the actual show they
kind of talk
during games which you don't actually do
in real in real actual tournaments
uh but netflix had to made it and make
it a little bit more
exciting so here uh beth says uh i don't
have to
for ex for some reason she says i don't
have to use my queen
even though there's no reason you could
even
use your queen here uh but okay bishop
to h3 blocking check and now there's a
problem
so what you have to do here is uh if you
want to even
try and save this game for black you
have to play rook to d3 and then you
have uh
very good chances because after rook to
f7 king g8 and rook captures here
uh you have rook to d to check picking
up uh the white queen so in fact you
could never pick up the knight
you have to be happy with an idea like
rook to f8 check king g7 and then
continue checking with
uh with the rook so this is
one way to go about the position however
after this bishop to h3 move
we have a different idea beltic plays
knight captures on g6
played it rather quickly but now like
well similarly to the game against
vasily borgov
elizabeth goes all in and
well it's just a very beautiful idea
here we have rook to f7
check king to h6 and now
uh or rather we could uh we could
consider capturing the rook as giving up
the queen for two rooks makes sense
sometimes although not here because
after queen to f5 check
king has to defend the night king g uh
seven now queen f6
czech king has to move and now bishop to
f5 threat of checkmate is here
rook g8 and now e6 e7 is coming the rook
is under attack
it's uh completely completely winning
for white
this is not even an attempt so here we
have king to
h6 and now uh feel free to pause the
video and to win the game for elizabeth
while i give you a couple of seconds
uh so for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
sacrificing your queen yet again in this
uh
queen's gambit netflix series uh well
series on youtube
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's queen captures on g6
brilliant brilliant line
and it's actually a forced chick made in
seven moves uh and here after elizabeth
played uh queen captures on g6 she asked
the beltic again during the game which
is
for those of you who are not uh chess
players and you know active chess
players who are in a chess club
you do not talk to your opponent during
a chess game like the only thing
you are allowed to ask your opponent is
do do you
want to draw or you just say draw
and i i don't think like there's
anything else you can say
you can say jadoob if you want to you
know fix the pieces if they're not
centralized but
you know other than that not not really
but it's a show so we have to respect
that she says
do you see it now or should we finish
this over the board
and here it was in this position that
harry beltic resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here however
i will show the continuation because in
the actual game
where this happened the game continued
all the way to checkmate
so we will show it so the uh entire game
went
king captures on g6 rook won the f6
check now driving the king down the
board king to g5 and now
rook to f5 with check we have king to g6
now rook 7 to f6 with check it was
important to have this rook um
to f5 so when the king moves you can go
to g5 and the h5
so king the h7 but now comes rook to h5
with
check the rook on f6 is nicely protected
boxing in the black
king so king to g7 now rook to g5
check and there is only one square left
for the black king which is the h7
square
and now who delivers checkmate well of
course our good friend
the bishop bishop to f5 and this is now
checkmate
so incredible game uh based on uh an
actual incredible game based on uh well
one of my
absolute favorite chess players now for
those of you who have been following the
channel for some time
uh obviously know that this game was
played but not by none other than the
great uh rasheed gabato which
medinav and uh he played the game in
1955 in the regal latvia with the
spartak team championship he played it
against
uh henrikh organic i don't know how it's
uh pronounced generic casparian
and it was a a brilliant brilliant game
but it's super interesting how both
elizabeth and rasheed medina missed the
positional c4
and rather went on with with the d you
know just uh no reverse gear h5 let's
bust open the position and
continue this and i'm very glad uh they
stuck with this uh
in the series uh as elizabeth is
portrayed as a really great attacker she
doesn't care about slow playing it she
doesn't care about end games
she just wants to you know sacrifice
anything everything and crush the
opponent
but i also enjoyed very much that they
actually showed um
that uh one of the people she meet meets
uh during the series
uh shows her that she could have played
uh c4 in that position so that was that
was really awesome
uh so yeah that's one more game from the
netflix
news series the queen's gambit i do hope
you enjoyed it uh maybe we'll
show some more maybe not we'll see how
it goes and how you guys uh you know
enjoy it
and i also decided to give you uh a
special assignment
after watching this video so i'm gonna
show you a very short clip from
from the series where elizabeth plays uh
one game
against her opponent uh so we're only
gonna show two moves and you guys have
to guess which
famous game this is i think uh it's the
most famous game ever played but just in
case
you don't know it we're gonna show it
and i'm sure just by browsing through
the comments
you will see which game i'm talking
about so here it is uh let's check it
out
so here elizabeth plays it there you
have it queen b8 uh
knight captures queen and there you have
it rook the d8 is checkmate uh
in case you missed it we can check it
out again so let's see that once again
there we go so i think this is the
absolute most
famous game ever played so it was a bit
weird for me that they
included this as a you know casual game
that was played like you know
like quickly but it was it was basically
a casual game in real life because the
person who played it
uh you know wasn't really paying all
that much attention to the
to the game as the as the story goes
however uh i will
put a link to this game in the
description below so if you guys want to
check out
this entire game that we've just seen
these two moves do check it out it's
an incredible game and also if you guys
are new to the channel or new to chess
and if you enjoy
a game such as this one do check out uh
the the
well the most viewed video on my channel
a game by none other than
rashid medina which this game is based
upon
also will be the first link in the
description below features the greatest
queen sacrifice
in chess history or so so i believe
uh so yeah uh that's uh the game i do
hope you enjoyed it uh
hope you guys have uh you know uh got a
chance to watch the show now as you know
it's
uh uh i i think it's uh the most popular
show on netflix in
like all the countries so you know
people are people are getting into chess
i mean
what more can we hope for so i'm very
happy about that
uh and uh yeah that's why i decided to
show uh another game and we might show
even another one
so we'll see so like i said i do hope
you enjoyed the game i would like to
thank
uh dylan streeter uh fred ackerman
alan ferns and liam daniel connolly for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh like the queen's gambit as like i
said we might show a few more games
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day